-As the US scrambles
to withdraw from Afghanistan
and complete the evacuation,
the same Republicans who
supported Donald Trump's deal
with the Taliban to withdraw
are now shamelessly piling on
and trying to erase history.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
In order to claim
that what's happening
in Afghanistan right now
came out of nowhere,
you have to willfully ignore
or erase 20 years of history
in which the Washington elite
repeatedly lied about
how the war was going,
which is exactly
what so many in the media,
and especially
the right-wing ghouls
who got us into this mess --
the Karl Roves
and John Boltons of the world
have been doing.
Donald Trump himself,
the guy who negotiated the deal
with the Taliban to release
prisoners and withdraw by May,
has been on TV claiming
he would have handled
the situation better.
And for some reason,
he's going out of his way
to compliment the Taliban
on their fighting
and negotiating skills.
-Taliban, great negotiators.
Tough fighters,
great negotiators.
The Taliban, good fighters.
I will tell you,
they're good fighters.
We have to give them
credit for that.
-No, you don't.
You don't have to give
the Taliban credit for anything.
They're the Taliban.
It's especially insane
to call them good negotiators
like they're trying to talk down
a used car salesman.
"This car has a lot
of miles on it,
but it runs like a champ.
Give it to me for free
or I'll murder your family."
"Oh, alright.
Tough, but fair, Mr. Taliban.
Let me talk to my manager.
And he's dead.
I'm going to get you the keys."
Does Trump think
if he's nice to the Taliban,
they'll hang out with him?
"Great fighters,
great negotiators
and great, great golfers.
Abdul Ghani Baradar,
horrible guy,
but I saw him eagle a par 5
from the rough.
We played in a foursome
with Brooks Koepka
and Bryson DeChambeau,
and you want to talk
about warring factions.
Those two do not
like each other."
I mean, thank God this idiot
wasn't the chief of police
in San Francisco
during the Zodiac killings.
"Bad guy. Nasty guy.
But you got to give him credit
for one thing --
beautiful, beautiful penmanship.
And I love those little puzzles.
Reminds me of the
"New York Times" spelling bee.
We love the pangram,
don't we, folks?
Don't we love
the pangram, Trump voters?"
If you don't know
what the pangram is,
you don't want to know.
It'll destroy your life.
Just -- is an evil game.
Yesterday,
I spent 11 hours on it
and then I finally got Genius,
and when I told my kids,
they said,
"We haven't eaten yet today."
And then there was
Trump's former
White House press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany.
Oh, pangram.
Nope. Never mind.
I didn't use the F.
Who went on Fox yesterday
and made it clear
she's fully inhabiting
an alternate reality.
-Look, when
President Trump was president,
you didn't see
crisis after crisis.
You just didn't see it.
I shudder to think about
what Covid would have
been like under Joe Biden.
-Well, she's right
about one thing --
you didn't see
crisis after crisis
if you were watching Fox.
More than 400,000 Americans
died from COVID under Trump.
Also, he got it,
and his rallies and White House
parties were superspreaders.
Trump personally helped
spread more disease
to more people than
a community swimming pool
filled with water
from the East River.
"Alright, everybody
out of the deep end.
We got another mobster.
Give me the long pole thing
with the hook on it.
You kids want to see
what happens
when you sing to the feds?"
Trump's entire presidency
was crisis after crisis.
His presidency
was such a disaster,
when it started,
I had an audience,
and now we cut to Wally
so often,
he's getting offers
to do Scorsese movies.
-Just one thing, Marty.
I don't curse.
[ Laughs ]
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm just [bleep] with you,
buddy.
-Take the sunglasses off.
To say Trump didn't cycle
through crises after crisis
is to ignore that much of
his inner circle got indicted,
his cabinet had, like, half
a dozen corruption scandals.
He praised Nazis,
kidnapped migrant children,
fired or tried to fire
the people investigating them,
got caught paying hush money
to a porn star,
incited a violent insurrection
to overthrow an election,
helped Saudi Arabia
cover up a murder,
single-handedly caused
the longest government shutdown
in American history,
and told the Boy Scouts a story
about yachts
and New York parties.
-When I was young,
there was a man
named William Levitt
and he was
a very successful man,
and he went out
and bought a big yacht,
and he had
a very interesting life.
I won't go any more than that
because you're a Boy Scouts,
so I'm not going to
tell you what he did.
Should I tell you?
[ Applause ]
Oh, you're Boy Scouts,
but you know life.
You know life.
-That's a thing that happened.
A bunch of 12-year-olds
who wanted to learn,
I don't know, about knots,
and he's up there saying,
"I don't know
if you give out badges
for having threeways
and blowing rails,
but if you did, you would have
run out in the '80s.
You're Boy Scouts. You know."
Look, I'm not saying
Joe Biden doesn't
screw up or make mistakes.
He does.
Watching him
take questions from reporters
can feel like watching
the grounds crew
roll out a tarp
in a hurricane.
Don't worry. They got it.
They got it. Oh! Oh, God!
Ohhh.
The tarp just swallowed Mr. Met.
Of course, based on
what's been happening
at Citi Field recently,
I think Mr. Met
would happily embrace
the sweet release of death.
"We're going to get you
out of there, Mr. Met!"
"Leave me to die."
So, Biden certainly
has made mistakes.
It's not like the withdrawal and
evacuation have been flawless,
even if it's
the right thing to do.
Even if the chaos was inevitable
after 20 years
of a failed quagmire
the foreign policy establishment
repeatedly lied about.
For one thing, the US should
evacuate and grant asylum
to any vulnerable Afghan
who wants to come here, period.
A community organizer helping
to evacuate vulnerable Afghans
wrote in
"The New York Times" yesterday,
"...we're coordinating
on different platforms
and languages,
often all at once.
We're figuring out what
Taliban checkpoints to avoid
and what gate at the airport is
the most accessible, if any are.
We're raising money,
millions of dollars overnight
to charter planes.
We're endlessly compiling
spreadsheets with information
about Afghans who are
under threat from the Taliban.
We're doing this because
the American government isn't.
That's inexcusable."
Shouldn't be on volunteers
and human rights activists
alone to figure out
which gates are
most accessible in Kabul,
since it's not even
an easy task at LaGuardia.
At LaGuardia,
there are no gates.
You just walk onto the tarmac
and hail a flight the way
you would a cab.
I swear, one time I printed out
my boarding pass
for a LaGuardia flight
to Los Angeles
and it told me
to go to Gate 65 in Terminal Z
near the haunted Cinnabon.
I should note,
we have to get our
LaGuardia jokes in while we can,
because they're doing
a major renovation
that it looks like
it's going to be pretty nice,
which sucks, because LaGuardia
is a perfect comedy word.
It's the Kalamazoo of airports.
And yesterday's pangram.
I'm starting to think the crew
is not doing the spelling bee.
[ Laughter ]
-Nonetheless, getting out
is the right thing to do,
and Americans support it.
In fact, Americans
have wanted us
to get out of this war
for a long time.
Polls have shown
that as many as 73% of Americans
want it to end, 73%.
Part of the problem is,
for years,
the media has all
but ignored Afghanistan.
But you know who wasn't
ignoring the war?
Defense contractors.
The Costs of War Project
at Brown University
estimates that since invading
Afghanistan in 2001,
the United States has spent
$2.313 trillion on the war.
And "The Intercept" calculated
that $10,000
invested in defense stocks
when the Afghanistan war began
is now worth almost $100,000,
because defense stocks
outperformed the stock market
overall by 58% percent
during the Afghanistan War.
Now, you don't have to know
much about the stock market
to know the defense contractors
profit from war,
which is why the Washington
elite are freaking out --
the same reason
your weed dealer freaked out
when they legalized it.
"What am I supposed to do?
Get a job? Sell coke?
Oh, that's it. I'll sell coke."
Also, I should clarify,
I have no idea
how the stock market works.
All I know is my broker
calls me once a day
and tells me how
my portfolio's looking.
[ Cellphone rings ]
Oh, that's him now. Hold on.
Hey, how's it looking?
[ Gasps ]
You invested in the Mets? When?
Three weeks ago?
What money did you use?
You sold our LaGuardia stock?
That's about to go sky high!
So the media has ignored
Afghanistan for years
and elite Washington
has lied to us about it,
as documented by
"The Washington Post's"
blockbuster reporting
on what we're known
is the Afghanistan Papers,
in which government officials
secretly admitted "we clearly
failed in Afghanistan"
and "we didn't know
what we were doing."
The US occupation of Afghanistan
began 20 years ago,
and for basically
that entire period,
our government has shielded us
from the reality
of what was happening.
George W. Bush
and Donald Rumsfeld
even went so far
as to make grandiose predictions
about how the war
would be viewed by history,
despite what they really knew
was happening behind the scenes.
-The history of military
conflict in Afghanistan,
it's been one
of initial success
followed by long years
of floundering
and ultimate failure.
We're not going to
repeat that mistake.
-What has taken place in the
last four years in Afghanistan
is an historic achievement.
And the people
who've been involved in it
can be enormously proud,
and history will look back on it
as having been
an amazing accomplishment,
-I'm honestly not sure
if these guys were
ever right about anything, ever.
Like, these guys were so wrong
about so many things.
There's a good chance
Don Rumsfeld
wasn't even his real name.
It sounds like an alias
Dick Whitman would use
to get a job at Raytheon.
Suffice to say,
history will not look back on it
as an amazing accomplishment.
If anything, I think
it's much more likely that
when they get to the chapter
on Afghanistan in future,
textbooks will just say
"file not found."
Of course, in the future, there
probably won't be textbooks.
You'll just get all your history
downloaded in a chip
that you put in your brain.
Okay, activate the chip.
[ Laughs ]
He said what to the Boy Scouts?
Hey, it's one thing to be wrong.
I make mistakes all the time,
as anyone who watches
our Emmy-nominated corrections
segment will tell you --
voting now open.
But what the Bushes
and Rumsfelds
and Boltons and Roves did
was so much worse,
because they lied
and covered up the truth
while they were cheerleading
and making all of those
confident predictions in public,
in private, we now know
they had no idea what
the [bleep] they were doing.
Despite declaring the war
an amazing accomplishment,
Rumsfeld repeatedly
wrote panicked memos
about the situation
in Afghanistan.
In 2003, he wrote,
"I have no visibility
into who the bad guys are."
In 2002, he ended one memo
by writing the word "Help!"
with an exclamation point.
And two months
after the US invaded,
Rumsfeld wrote to an aide,
"Please give me a piece of paper
showing me the languages
spoken in Afghanistan."
Feel like it would
have been preferable
to get that information
before invading.
That's like an old Western
where the marshal
kicks in the door
of a Mexican cantina.
"Hey, everyone, throw your guns
on the ground.
Oh, right. Hmm. Oh, boy.
Todos...
armas?
It's been awhile, guys."
Elites watched and lied to us
for 20 years about the war,
telling us it was
historic achievement
and that we were
close to victory,
when in reality, they knew
and admitted in private
that it was a disaster.
And now the right-wing ghouls
who got us into this mess
are opining shamelessly
on cable news about
how they would have
handled the situation,
and the pro-Trump crowd
that negotiated
and celebrated the deal
with the Taliban to withdraw
are hypocritically piling
on Biden for following through.
But then again, you probably
expected that would happen,
because --
-You know life. You know life.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.